Uh greetings. I am B uh undergraduate
students of Taspajaran.
Uh I have the permission of the
committee and I would like to ask three
questions.
>> Can you can you speak a bit loudly and
into the mic?
>> Uh greetings.
I am B undergraduate students of
Taspajaran. I have the permission of the
committee and I would like to ask three
questions before I can uh maybe accept
Islam name.
>> So name
>> the first question is
>> what is the ruling of people who have
never heard of Islam in their life and
how will they be judged on the day of
judgment?
>> And the second question is
>> can you please ask one question at a
time? Okay.
>> Please, may I know your name, brother?
What's your name and what's your
religion?
>> Uh, BM Christian.
>> PM is your name?
>> Yeah.
>> And you're a Christian?
>> I just want to make a correction that in
the last time when I was speaking to the
sister, I made a sip of the tongue,
maybe I said, uh, Muhammad is God, Jesus
is God. What I meant was Muhammad is a
messenger of God. Jesus is the messenger
of God. So, the word messenger was
missing. So someone just reminded me
that it sounded like you know Jesus is
God and Muhammad is God. Jesus is the
messenger of God and prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God peace be upon them
both. PM has asked a question he's a
Christian that what is the ruling if the
message of Islam has not reached to a
non-Muslim. Correct.
>> Yes.
The ruling is
that today in this age
of science and technology, Islam is a
global religion. No sorry, the the the
whole world is a global village. The
whole world is a global village. Before
I give you answer, I would like to
mention a point. Our beloved prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that every child is born in fra
he's born in the innate religion he's
born as a Muslim later on is influenced
by his parents his teachers and friends
he starts doing idol worship fire
worship and he changes there were two
research it's done in the in the Kapoku
tribe and the Australian aborigence this
research was done in 1950
at that time these people did not come
in contact with modern civilization. So
when the researchers went and tried to
find out what was the way of life, it
was everything like Islam except in
name. They believed there's one God.
They prostrated for worshiping that God.
They believe that God had no son. Same.
But they didn't call themsel Muslims. So
if there is no external influence on a
human being after he's born, he
continues to remain in the innate nature
which is called as Islam.
Now coming to your question, what if the
message of Islam has not reached to any
human being?
If the message of Islam has not reached,
Allah says in the Quran in surah fuss
chapter number 41 verse number 53
that soon we shall show them our signs
in the furthest regions of the horizons
until it is clear to them that this is
the truth. Here Allah is taking it upon
himself
that he will deliver the message to
every human being personally.
Number one, a beloved prophet said the
pen is lifted from a person
if he's not an adult.
If a person is a young child, four
years, 5 years, 6 years, and something
happens to him, he's not responsible
because he's
innocent.
Only once you become an adult are you
responsible for your actions.
So anyone who's a kid, if he's a small
child, 5 years, 6 years, 7 years, before
he becomes an adult, he will go to
Jenna, there are two views. One view go
to Jenna because
he's not responsible for his actions.
One view says some scholars say no no on
the day of judgment he'll be tested and
based on his reply he'll go to hell or
heaven but I believe in the first view
that since he's innocent he'll go to
Jenna now your question what if a person
hasn't heard about Islam today in this
world which is a global village it is
difficult to find a human being who has
not heard Islam
satellite channels are there social
media is
internet is there. Yes, he may have
heard less. But to say he doesn't know
about Islam is extremely difficult but
even hypothetically you find one human
being in one corner of the world maybe
in the forest of Africa or some island.
So there Allah says in surah fusil 41
verse number 53 that Allah will deliver
the message to him directly. So once
Allah delivers the message on the day of
judgment, he cannot object that I did
not get the message. But after getting
the message, he may not want to accept
because oh what will my father say? What
will my mother say? Oh, I've got a good
business of alcohol. If I accept Islam,
I'll have to stop my business of
alcohol. There may be many worldly thing
that may stop. Like the sister before
you, she agrees there's one God. She
agrees Jesus is not God. She agrees
Jesus is the messenger of God peace be
upon him. She agrees prophet Muhammad is
is the messenger of God. But yet she may
be thinking what will my mother say?
What will my father say? So many things
even after you come to know the truth
I'm asking you the question on the day
of judgment can she say that she did not
get the message of Islam. Can she say
that brother?
>> No.
>> Very good. She'll be responsible.
So on the day of judgment she cannot say
I will give shada
I gave the message to a right or wrong.
Similarly on the day of judgment Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala himself gives the
message to every human being.
Allah says soon he will show them his
signs. What are his signs? the sun, the
moon, the stars, all these are signs of
Allah. He will show them the signs in
the furthest regions of the horizons
until the person believes
this is the truth.
Therefore, in the Quran on the day of
judgment, no non-Muslim will say, "Oh
God,
why you doing injustice to me?" No
non-Muslim will say, "Why you putting me
to hell?"
They will only say please give us one
more chance and Allah will say the
chance is over. Do you understand? So
Quran says on the day of judgment no
non-Muslim will object to the justice of
Allah. Today someone can say no one told
me on the day of judgment they cannot
tell a lie to Allah. Correct?
So Allah takes it upon himself that when
a person gets an adult when he becomes
an adult before he dies Allah will give
him the message whether we can it's our
job to convey the message correct every
Muslim's job whether we do our job
properly or not Allah himself will
convey the message so I believe in those
group of followers who say that
non-Muslim if he doesn't accept Islam
even if he doesn't get the message Allah
has given him he will be responsible
Some scholars say no if he has not got
the message on the day of judgment
message will be given to him and
depending upon his answer the ruling
will be given do you understand there
are two opinion but I believe in the
first group of scholars that Allah gives
the message directly if he's a kid he'll
go to Jenna directly if he's adult he
has got the message he'll be responsible
so hope that answers the question
brother did you get the message of Islam
or not
>> yes
>> do you believe there's one god
Uh yes.
>> Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God?
>> Yes.
>> Do you believe that Jesus Christ peace
be upon me, he's a messenger or is he
God?
>> A messenger.
>> Mashallah. So brother, I am asking the
question, what is stopping you from
accepting Islam?
>> Uh can I ask the second and third
question first?
>> Sure. Most you're most welcome. Second
question.